hi I'm Kate they're having me on cuz I'm
a super huge name in the comedy world
just kidding I'm here to promote rough
and rowdy red white and bruised coming
up on Friday July 19 bye Erin are calm
it's amateur fighters we got ankle
bracelets jean shorts in the ring all
that [__] it's a [__] show who would win
a fight a Navy SEALs brain in a
toddler's body or a toddler's brain in a
Navy SEALs body oh I'm gonna have to go
with a toddler's brain in the Navy SEALs
body no offense to the Navy SEALs but I
feel like that's already kind of what's
going on who is the hottest celebrity
you think you have a shot with if they
got to know you
Viggo Mortensen the bathhouse scene and
Eastern Promises dick swingin he's on my
bucket list I'm sure he's watching this
right now Viggo would you rather kill 25
kittens in a row or one dog I'd rather
kill 25 kittens with one dog could one
tank take out the Roman Empire unlimited
gas and weapons mmm I feel like I've
seen enough tank screw up videos online
that I don't think so I think it would
get stuck in a moat like immediately by
some driver who wasn't paying attention
so no would you rather know when you're
going to die or how you're going to die
I'm a smoker so I already know would you
rather be married to someone extremely
attractive or be extremely attractive oh
I would rather be married to someone
extremely attractive what a flex again
Viggo what's up if you are a war general
in the Civil War and you got the choice
of bringing a t-rex or a modern war tank
on your side what are you taking Oh
t-rex hands down come riding in on that
thing a little hands pumping would you
rather be a superhero or be extremely
rich extremely rich hands down Fox oops
opportunities would you rather be able
to eat as much as you want without
getting fat or never have to pay for a
meal again never have to pay for a meal
again for sure my seamless bill no free
odds
oof right now would you rather be drunk
24/7 or never get drunk again oh I'll go
with never get drunk again because I
dabble in a couple other things too
would you rather go to jail for one year
or go to jail with a Rubik's Cube and
you can leave when it's done jail for
one year I have never unless I can cheat
and switch the stickers around that'll
be the only well then yeah one year I'll
take it yeah if your bellybutton was a
real button and you could push it once a
day to make anything happen
what would you do have I killed the
Viggo Mortensen thing yet cuz I would
just use it and then bury B who is the
one president you would want to get
shit-faced with oh one president I want
to get shit-faced with I would say JFK I
want to be on the yacht surrounded by
beautiful women no wait I don't know why
I would want that I just want to be
drunk on a yacht with JFK yeah would you
rather your partner always have a huge
bush or you always have a huge bush well
there's already an answer there that's
true life it is the latter
so I'll just roll with that what's one
thing a person can say or do that makes
you immediately hate them soft talkers
people talk like this to me it makes me
crazy inside I don't want you to talk
sweet to me just talk to me I can't hear
you you have to choose between sex on
the first date or sex on the 19th date
what are you picking is this a real
question obviously it's sex on the first
John Legend and Chrissy tight Chrissy
tagging well it worked for John Legend
and Chrissy Teigen hopefully it works
for me if you could bring like one
person from the dead who would it be
I'm gonna go with that happy paint guy
he was like the best ASMR you could ever
have Bob Ross I'm bringing them back
bringing them right here to barstool
sports in fact have them paint up some
nice pretty little yeah would you rather
sit down with your parents and watch
every sexual encounter you've had or
watch your parents sex tape when they
conceived you excuse me
ah God
I'd watch the sex tape when they
conceived me I guess I kind of want to
know what was it reverse cowgirl is it
like what which way did I come in I
don't know I'm kind of curious see if it
explains anything about Who I am now if
you got to make one fashion trend in or
out what would it be
I would make being poor in guess
everything on one things from Goodwill
right now if you had to go to war would
you rather fight in the Middle Ages like
Braveheart during the Revolutionary War
in muskets and cannons or World War one
in the trenches actually I'm a Marine
Corps veteran and I did go to
Afghanistan two times so I've been your
welcome everyone and you can hear all
about it on zero blog thirty barstool
sports military podcast check it out if
you could only watch one category of
porn for the rest of your life what
would it be
Owen gray I'm gonna admit it who's my
favorite porn star hands down big fan
that's the guy I'm watching all about he
cares he cares if the women come he
cares Oh
salute would you rather have everyone
naked all the time or everyone clothed
all the time
riding on the subway in the busses in
New York City clothed all the time I
don't want what anybody else is putting
out I am fine as this with my jeans on
would you rather fart popcorn or sneeze
butter tough to say but I know I'll be
eating popcorn and [__] and butter all
over there sorry
round two
would you rather fart popcorn or sneeze
butter I'm gonna go with sneeze butter
because I'll be eatin popcorn while I
watch rough and rowdy 9 next Friday July
19th sneeze and butter all over my
popcorn watch an amateur boxing in the
ring we got ankle monitors jean shorts
people and kids up there doing whatever
reason it is my favorite favorite boxing
event of the Year by R&R calm
[Applause]